♪ ♪
>> Kimberly: MAJOR
DEVELOPMENTS COMING OUT OF
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT THE BIGGEST
SECURITY THREAT.
THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE ISSUING THIS ALARM.
>> FRANKLY THE UNITED STATES IS
UNDER ATTACK.
UNDER ATTACK BY ENTITIES THAT
ARE USING CYBER TO PENETRATE
VIRTUALLY EVERY MAJOR ACTION
THAT TAKES PLACE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
FROM U.S. BUSINESSES TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT, THE
UNITED STATES IS THREATENED BY
CYBER ATTACKS EVERY DAY.
>> Kimberly: DIRECTOR COATS
WARNED RUSSIA MAY BE ALREADY
TRYING TO MEDDLE IN THIS YEAR'S
MIDTERMS.
>> WE EXPECT RUSSIA TO CONTINUE
USING PROPAGANDA, SOCIAL MEDIA,
SYMPATHETIC SPOKESMAN AND OTHER
MEANS TO INFLUENCE TO TRY TO
BUILD HIS WIDE RANGE OF
OPERATIONS AND EXACERBATE SOCIAL
AND POLITICAL FIGURES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE SHOULD BE NO NOTE
RUSSIA -- NO DOUBT RUSSIA
PERCEIVED ITS PAST EFFORT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND VIEWS THE U.S.
MIDTERM ELECTIONS AS A POTENTIAL
TARGET FOR RUSSIAN INFLUENCE
OPERATIONS.
>> Kimberly: DANA, THIS IS
SORT OF BEEN IN THE WORKS.
WHAT KIND OF NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT THE RUSSIANS POSE AND NOW
LOOKING AT A TARGET OF THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
>> Dana: THIS HEARING WAS
SUPER INTERESTING.
ALL ABOUT THESE DIFFERENT
THREATS.
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM.
THIS WAS THE ONE THAT GOT SOME
ATTENTION.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
DEMOCRATS REALLY WANT TO
RELITIGATE 2016, AND THERE IS
NOT EVIDENCE THERE WAS RUSSIAN
MEDDLING IN THE ACTUAL MACHINES
THAT CHANGED VOTES BUT I DON'T
IS QUESTIONING WHETHER OR NOT
THEY TRIED TO INFLUENCE THROUGH
OTHER MEANS.
FALSE FLAGS.
IT'S CLEAR THE GOVERNMENT HASN'T
DONE ENOUGH TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO GOING
FORWARD.
PART IF IT IS AMERICANS ARE
QUITE HAVE TO BE SMART ABOUT THE
INFORMATION THEY CONSUME.
THAT'S OKAY.
IN A DEMOCRACY, WE CAN TRUST
VOTERS TO DO THAT.
IN THE MEANTIME IT'S THE OTHER
THREATS THAT ARE ALSO A PROBLEM.
BILL GATES TODAY ISSUED HIS
ANNUAL LETTER TO MICROSOFT
EMPLOYEES IN WHICH HE SAID
SOMETHING GREG HAS HAD FOR MANY
YEARS WHICH IS THAT WHEN YOU
MARRY THIS PRETTY EASY
TECHNOLOGY WITH BIOLOGICAL
AGENTS, GET THEM PUT ON A DRONE
AND SEND IT INTO THE CITY.
ALL THESE THINGS ARE EMERGING
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A SUPER
POWER IN ORDER TO WAGE WAR.
ONE PERSON IN YOUR BASEMENT
WORKING ON IT.
>> Kimberly: GREG.
YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH ONE PERSON
IN YOUR BASEMENT.
>> Greg: AT ME OR LOU DOBBS
DEPENDING ON WHAT DAY OF THE
WEEK IT IS.
THE TOP SECURITY THREAT IS
TECHNOLOGY MARRIED TO TARA.
YOU DON'T NEED 10,000 JIHADISTS.
YOU JUST NEED ONE WITH KNOW-HOW.
IT'S NOT LIKE A NATION-STATE
WHICH HAS EVERYTHING TO LOSE.
NORTH KOREA AND RUSSIA STILL
WANT TO SURVIVE BECAUSE THEIR
GOAL.
OUR BIGGEST FEAR OR DANGER IS
OUR OWN COMPLACENCY.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE JIHADIST
THREAT.
TOXIC IDEOLOGY AND WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IT.
ABOUT THE CYBER TERROR THING, WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL WHEN WE KEEP
SAYING WE ARE UNDER ATTACK.
OBVIOUSLY RUSSIANS ARE GOING TO
SPY.
NORTH KOREANS ARE GOING TO SPY.
THE CHINESE ARE GOING TO SPY.
EVERYBODY'S SPIES.
WE LOOK AT SPYING US ON HOW A
DEFENSIVE TOOL, LIKE WE'RE GOING
TO GET INFORMATION.
WE ARE GOING TO GET INFORMATION
ABOUT THE USSR OR RUSSIA AND
THAT'S HOW WE CREATE OUR
DEFENSES.
THE PROBLEM WITH PACKING IS WHEN
YOU SAY SOMEBODY HACKS.
NORTH KOREA, RUSSIA HACKS.
WE THINK OF IT AS A NATION.
WE THINK IT'S A NATION ATTACKING
US.
I THINK THAT'S A BIT DANGEROUS.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS THE WAY
WE LOOK AT NORMAL SPYING.
HACKING IS AN ADAPTATION OF THE
SPYING.
IT'S NOT A NATION ON THE
OFFENSIVE.
IS PERHAPS A SPY ON THE DEFENSE.
IT IS STILL BAD BUT WE HAVE TO
PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE SO WE
DON'T MISTAKE A DEFENSE OF
ACTION AS AN OFFENSIVE ONE AND
LAUNCH A WAR.
THAT'S MY THEORY I'VE STOLEN
FROM SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> Kimberly: WHEN YOU WANT TO
GET BACK TO US WITH THE
ATTRIBUTION.
>> Greg: I DON'T REMEMBER WHAT
WAS.
>> Kimberly: THAT IS EVERYONE.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE RUSSIAN
CYBER THREAT IS REAL.
THE RUSSIANS PUT $100,000 ON
FACEBOOK ADS THE LAST ELECTION.
HILLARY CLINTON SPENT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON FACEBOOK
ADS.
HER CAMPAIGN SPENT $1.1 BILLION
IN ADVERTISING.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUTSIDE GROUPS,
1.4 BILLION IN ADVERTISING.
WHEN YOU ADD THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA PROPAGANDA TO THAT,
COMBINED THAT WITH HILLARY,
THERE IS MUCH MORE ANTI-TRUMP
PROPAGANDA AND THEN THERE WAS
PRO PROPAGANDA IN THE ELECTION.
>> Kimberly: PURCHASED
INFLUENCE.
>> Jesse: THE BIGGEST
INFLUENCE I BELIEVE OF RUSSIA
PROPAGANDA IN THE LAST ELECTION
WAS THE DOSSIER.
PAID FOR BELL HILLARY CLINTON --
PAID FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IT A YEAR
LATER.
THE DNC CLAIMS THEY WERE HACKED
BY THE RUSSIANS BUT THEY NEVER
HANDED OVER THEIR SERVER.
HOW SERIOUSLY DO THEY TAKE IT?
JOHN PODESTA SAID HE WAS HACKED
BY THE RUSSIANS.
HE ENDED UP GIVING THEM HIS
PASSWORD.
PRESIDENT OBAMA ADMITTED HE WAS
WORRIED ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN THE ELECTION AND
NEVER SAID ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
ACTUALLY FEELS GUILTY.
I AM FRIENDS WITH A GUY WHO RUNS
THE HARVARD CYBER SECURITY TEAM
AND HE BRIEFED CONGRESS AND HE
SAID IT'S LIKE A CRIME.
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO FULLY
PREVENT IT.
YOU HAVE TO REALIZE SOME OF IT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN BUT WHEN
RUSSIA COMES TO MESS WITH US, WE
HAVE TO GET THEM BACK HARD SO
THEY PAY A PRICE.
>> Kimberly: WELL, GOOD.
JUAN, SWIVEL FOR ME.
>> Juan: IT SEEMS LIKE PEOPLE
ARE PUTTING ON BLINDERS SO THEY
HAVE DON'T HAVE TO SAY RUSSIA
INFLUENCE THE 2016 ELECTION.
WE SHOULD KNOW THE DETAILS SO WE
CAN PREVENT AN OCCURRENCE IN THE
FUTURE.
WHAT WE HEARD TODAY WAS THIS IS
AN ONGOING ASSAULT.
IT IS AN OLD OFFENSIVE RESULT.
IN THE COURSE OF THE BUDGET
SHUTDOWN THERE WAS A HASHTAG
CALLED #SchumerShutdown
TRENDING.
GOT LOTS OF ATTENTION AND
AMPLIFIED BY MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS IN THE
MIDST OF THEIR EFFORT TO SAY WE
ARE GOING TO BLAME IT ON THE
REPUBLICAN SAID LOOK AT HOW
SOCIAL MEDIA IS PLAYING.
LATER IT COMES OUT THE POOL
SUPPORTED THE DEMOCRATS BUT THE
RUSSIANS, THE BOTS AND THEIR
PROPAGANDA EFFORTS, WERE PUSHING
HASHTAG #SchumerShutdown.
THIS GOES ON EVERY DAY THESE
DAYS ON EVERY POLITICAL ISSUE IN
AMERICA WHERE PUBLIC OPINION IS
INFLUENCED FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THE RUSSIANS.
WE CANNOT SIT SILENT AS
AMERICANS AND SAY IT COULD BE
THAT THIS COUNTRY, THAT COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO THE TOP
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
TESTIFYING TODAY, IT'S RUSSIA,
IRAN, CHINA.
IF WE WANT TO PROTECT OUR
DEMOCRACY, OUR BASIC,
FUNDAMENTAL, WE HAVE TO GET
SERIOUS.
>> Greg: CAN I RESPOND TO
THAT?
THIS ISSUE IS DAMAGING THAT IT
THRIVES ON TEAM SPORT POLITICS.
FOR RUSSIA, IT'S ABOUT
DISRUPTING OUR FOUNDATION.
THE WAY IT DISRUPTS OUR
FOUNDATION IS BY SPLITTING US.
WE ARE SPENDING ALL THIS ENERGY
QUARRELING OVER WHO DO THE
RUSSIANS HELP.
WHO DID THEY HURT?
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT A GLOBAL
PRANKSTER WANTS.
THE SOLUTION, WE HAVE TO STEP
BACK AND SAY THERE AREN'T TWO
OPPOSITIONAL SIDES.
BOTH SIDES, JUAN AND MYSELF, WE
SHOULD RELINQUISH THIS
TRIBALISTS.
WE CAN AGREE THERE IS RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE.
I KNOW THERE IS.
THERE ALWAYS WILL BE.
YOU HAVE TO THINK THERE MIGHT
NOT BE EVIDENCE THERE WAS
ANOTHER SIDE TO IT, THAT TRUMP
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
>> Juan: I AM OPEN TO THE
INVESTIGATION BUT WHEN I AM
SAYING THERE CAN BE NO DEBATE
ABOUT WHAT TOOK PLACE.
>> Kimberly: WE GET IT.
EVERYONE KNOWS, THE U.S.